Este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a Elsa,
la app puntera de inteligencia artificial
que te ayuda a mejorar tu inglés.
Más sobre esto en un momento.
¿Os habéis fijado en estas imagenes?
Pues puede que te sorprenda pero perfectamente
podrían haber sido Buenos Aires.
En junio del año 1806, la por aquel entonces
capital del Virreinato del Río de la Plata
fue invadida por los ingleses, los cuales,
al cabo de un par de meses fueron expulsados.
Al año siguiente se volvió a presentar la
misma situación…
con idéntico resultado.
Así que hoy la coña entre algunos argentinos
es que, si no hubiera sido por esa acción
heróica de los criollos, Argentina podría
ser actualmente como Australia.
Por supuesto, en realidad no podemos saber
qué hubiera ocurrido, y desde luego si algo
nos dice la historia es que el éxito o el
fracaso de un país depende sobre todo de
las instituciones que se hubieran implementado.
El caso de Argentina, del que tantas veces
hemos hablado, es buena prueba de ello.
Hemos hecho un montón de vídeos sobre Argentina,
pero nos faltaba un tema clave:
Al ver el estado en el que se encuentra hoy
este país, puede parecernos un mito, casí,
casí una historia marciana de ciencia ficción,
pero lo cierto es que hubo un tiempo en que
la Argentina fue un país muy rico, uno de
los países más ricos del mundo, que llegó
a ser, incluso, el más rico de todos.
La pregunta es, ¿es esto posible?
¿Realmente la Argentina fue un lugar tan
rico?
Y de ser así, ¿Por qué demonios era tan
diferente al país con el que hoy nos encontramos?
Y una pregunta también muy importante: con
la alergia que los políticos argentinos le
tienen al comercio internacional y al capital
extranjero, ¿qué papel jugaron estos en
esa supuesta era dorada?
Pues bien…
Veámoslo.
[Pero antes de continuar, ¿no os ha pasado
alguna vez que habéis creído estar seguros
de cómo se pronuncia una palabra en inglés
y con los años habéis descubierto que vivíais
en una mentira?
Ahora os cuento, por cierto, un ejemplo nuestro
real.
Bueno, el caso es que atentos porque Elsa
viene al rescate de todos nosotros.
La revolucionaria inteligencia artificial
de Elsa te ayuda a corregir tus errores de
pronunciación en inglés, mejorando tu entonación
y fluidez.
Pero eso no es todo, con Elsa también reforzarás
tu vocabulario, te ayudará a tener en tu
mente frases del día a día realmente útiles
(por ejemplo, la típica conversación de
ascensor, o al coger un taxi).
Con todo esto irás mejorando tu dominio del
inglés prácticamente sin darte cuenta.
Por ejemplo, volviendo a lo de las palabras
engañosas, ¿sabrías decirme de dónde era
gobernador Bill Clinton antes de ser presidente
de los Estados Unidos?
Tic tac tic tac…
Exacto, de Arkansas.
¿Y cómo pronunciaríais este estado en inglés?
Nosotros hemos hecho una prueba entre buena
parte del equipo y el fallo ha sido generalizado.
Si has dicho también “Arkansas”, el suspenso
de Elsa también es compartido contigo:
Y después de la ayuda de Elsa, la cosa mejoró
algo como podéis ver:
No esperes más y mejora tu inglés con la
inteligencia artificial de Elsa desde ya,
tienes una versión totalmente gratuita y
si quieres ir a por la versión pro, con el
link que te dejamos te llevas 7 días gratis
para que lo pruebes y un 85% de descuento
en la suscripción de por vida, o un 40% de
descuento en tu plan anual, lo que prefieras.
Te dejamos todos los links abajo]
(EL ORIGEN DE UNA NACIÓN)
A finales del siglo XVIII la corona española
decidió crear el Virreinato del Río de la
Plata situándo la capital en la ciudad de
Buenos Aires.
En aquel tiempo esta región lejana y poco
habitada no era particularmente interesante
para el Imperio español.
Sin embargo, el contrabando inglés y la expansión
portuguesa desde Brasil hicieron que la corona
se fijará en este lugar y comenzara a preocuparse
más por él.
De ahí que decidieran establecer una presencia
más importante en la región.
Sin embargo, el declive del imperio, su mala
salud económica, la ocupación de España
por parte de las tropas de Napoleón y la
difusión de l la ilustración hicieron que
se desencadenaran entre los años 1810 y 1825
movimientos independentistas en todas los
territorios americanos del Imperio prácticamente
con la única excepción de Cuba y Puerto
Rico.
De esta forma, entre los territorios separatistas
estaba lo que hoy conocemos como Argentina,
que el 25 de mayo de 1810 depuso al Virrey
Cisneros para proclamar un gobierno local.
Digamos que la excusa formal fue que con el
rey de España encarcelado por Napoleón,
el poder regresaba al pueblo.
Pues bien, apenas 6 años más tarde, el 9
de julio de 1816 la Argentina declaró su
independencia definitiva…
Aunque eso no trajo la paz: los conflictos
y las guerras locales se sucedieron.
En juego estaba quienes ocuparían el gobierno
y que tipo de gobierno se establecería..
Fundamentalmente aquí hubo dos grandes facciones:
los unitarios y los federales.
Y es que, veréis, el conflicto quedó muy
condicionado por el poder que acumulaba Buenos
Aires respecto al resto de provincias.
Como en Buenos Aires se encontraba el puerto
y la aduana, que eran las dos principales
fuentes de riqueza, este territorio consideraba
que tenía que tener más derechos que el
resto.
Por su parte, las provincias del interior
defendían que esos recursos pertenecían
a todos, que debían ser compartidos en partes
iguales y que no debían existir derechos
extarordinarios.
Pues bien, sea como sea el conflicto se alargó
casi 50 años.
La disputa sólo se terminaría por resolver
a mediados del siglo XIX cuándo se aprobó
la Constitución de 1853 y se federalizó
la ciudad de Buenos Aires en 1880.
Pero, ¿Sabéis qué?
Tras la proclamación de independencia, la
aprobación de esta Constitución fue algo
así como el segundo momento fundacional de
la Argentina.
A partir de ese momento fue cuándo realmente
comenzó a construirse la Argentina y cuándo
empezarón a ponerse en pie las instituciones
que cambiaron por completo el país y lo pusieron
en dirección a los primeros puestos del mundo.
¿Y sabéis que?
Justo aquí es dónde aparece uno de los nombres
claves de la historia argentina: Juan Bautista
Alberdi, quien fue considerado el padre de
la Constitución pese no haber participado
en la Convención Constituyente.
Sin embargo, publicó un libro titulado “Bases
y puntos de partida para la organización
política de la República Argentina” fue
la obra que más influyó en la Constitución.
Practicamente se epuede decir que sentó sus
bases.
Pero, ¿Por qué os estamos contando esto
en VisualPolitik?
Pues porque en esta obra Alberdi plantea cuáles
eran los obstáculos a los que se enfrentaba
el país para conseguir el desarrollo.
Cómo en aquel momento la Argentina no contaba
con metales preciosos, ni grandes poblaciones,
ni estaba cerca del mundo desarrollado, necesitaba
un marco político muy competitivo que le
permitiera que el país se sumara a la Segunda
Revolución Industrial.
En esta línea Alberdi detectó cuatro obstáculos
principales que tenían que superar para dejar
atrás la pobreza y poder despegar:
La falta de capital;
La escasez de poblacion; pensad que en aquel
momento el país era practicamente un lugar
deshabitad con una población de apenas 2
millones de personas.
La falta de infraestructuras;
Y la falta de seguridad jurídica, sobre todo
en lo que se refiere a garantizar la propiedad
privada y la libertad de empresa.
[No sé, casi que podría parecer que hablamos
del siglo XXI pero lo cierto es que lo estamos
haciendo del siglo XIX: Ya veis que muchos
de los problemas se repiten una y otra vez.
De hecho casí que podríamos decir que en
muchos casos la Argentina de hoy ha retrocedido
casi 200 años atrás en el tiempo.]
Pero no nos desviemos…
La cuestión es que todas estas preocupaciones
se recogieron en la Constitución de 1853
que dió vía libre a la llegada de inversiones
extranjeras e inmigrantes, garantizó la propiedad
privada y promovió el desarrollo de ferrocarriles.
Y así con la nueva constitución durante
los tres primeros presidentes de la Argentina,
Bartolomé Mite, Domingo Faustino Sarmiento
y Nicolás Avellaneda el país coménzo a
prosperar.
Un proceso que se acelerá a partir de 1880
cuándo el país quedó completamente pacificado,
se integró la ciudad de Buenos Aires como
capital federal y se incorporó la Patagonia.
A partir de ese momento se puso en marcha
el periodo de mayor crecimiento económico
de la historia del país.
Hablamos de un proceso que se extendió durante
algo más de 50 años y que situaría a la
Argentina entre los 10 países más ricos
y prósperos del mundo en la primera década
del siglo XX.
En aquel momento el sueño argentino era el
equivalente al sueño americano.
En menos de cuatro décadas el país se convirtió
en uno de los principales productores de alimentos
del mundo con cerca de 12 millones de hectareas
sembradas, 5 millones de toneladas de granos
exportados y millones de cabezas de ganado.
Y eso no es todo.
El país también tenía una de las infraestructuras
más modernas del mundo con grandes puertos,
tranvias urbanos y 28 mil kilómetros de vías
ferreas que recorrían todo el país.
Ahora bien, llegados hasta aquí, la pregunta
qué tenemos que hacernos es….
Exactamente, ¿Cómo cambió la Argentina
y que hizo que su economía despegara hasta
convertirse en una de las más ricas y prósperas
de todo el mundo?
¿Podemos encontrar algún ejemplo concreto
de toda esta prosperidad?
Pues lo cierto es que podemos destacar 4 grandes
cambios que marcaron un antes y un despúes.
Atentos, porque a continuación vamos a ver
cómo cambió exactamente este país.
Este es un ejemplo de lo que se puede conseguir
en muy pocos años.
Atentos.
OBJETIVO SOÑADO)
Siguiendo las bases de Alberdi la Constitución
de 1853 no sólo abrió las puertas a la inmigración
sino que la promovió con la idea de poblar
un gigantesco territorio que estaba prácticamente
desierto.
De esta forma, entre finales del XIX y principios
del XX, llegaron millones y millones de europeos
en busca de una vida mejor.
Para que os hagais una idea, Argentina era
el segundo destino favorito de los europeos
tan sólo por detrás de Estados Unidos.
Desde inicios del siglo XX, la inmigración
estuvo en constante incremento.
En 1905 la población era ya de 5.803.000
habitantes, y en apenas seis años más creció
en un millòn más.
C1 (“¿Y a qué vas a la Argentina?”
“Pues a lo que todos: a ver si salgo de
pobre”.
Diálogo entre el profesor de Derecho Político
Adolfo Posada y un inmigrante español en
1910)
La pregunta es, ¿qué ofrecía este país?
Pues además de mucho trabajo, había también
salarios mucho más altos.
Por ejemplo, gracias a la enorme prosperidad
que se respiraba los salarios que recibián
los inmigrantes españoles en Argentina triplicaban
los salarios que recibían en España.
Y para el caso de los Italianos se duplicaban.
Por supuesto, no todo era tan maravilloso.
El trabajo duro y las protestas sociales estaban
a la orden, pero, claro, con los datos en
la mano no resulta extraño que cuando llegaba
un inmigrante al poco tiempo convencían a
sus parientes y amigos de hacer las maletas
y mudarse a vivir el sueño argentino.
Y estbo hizo no solo que la población del
país se disparase sino que además creció
mucho más que la población de países como
Canadá o Australia.
Fijaos.
¿Sorprendidos?
Pues…
Sigamos.
(LAS ARTERIAS DE UNA NUEVA POTENCIA)
Otro de los grandes cambios y al mismo tiempo
otro de los factores que impulsaron la economía
gaucha fue el desarrollo de una moderna red
de ferrocarril.
Claro, en un país tan extenso y con pocos
rios navegables, el ferrocarril era una infraestructura
clave para poder transportar mercancías de
forma rápida y barata.
La buena noticia es que en aquella época
los dirigentes del país tenían esto muy
claro.
Así que pbronto comenzaron a construirse
miles y miles de kilómetros de nuevas líneas.
Entre 1865 y 1910 la red ferroviaria pasó
de menos de 500 km a más de 30.000.
Las vías unían Bolivia con Puerto Deseado,
los Andes con el Atlántico y la Pampa Húmeda
con el puerto de Buenos Aires, que es por
donde entraba y salía casi el 80% del comercio
internacional.
Para qué os hagais una idea, en 1910 la Argentina
ocupaba el puesto número diez a nivel mundial
por el avance del ferrocarril.
Y ojo porque en relación a la superficie,
la red argentina era mayor que la red de Canadá
o Australia.
Pero aquí no termina todo.
Sigamos.
(LA RULETA DE LA PROSPERIDAD)
Otro de los cambios fue la enorme expansión
que experimentó la economía argentina.
Esto ya lo hemos dicho…
Es en cierto modo el tema de este vídeo.
Pero, ¿hasta qué punto era la Argentina
próspera?
Pues…
Veréis, Según las estimaciones de Angus
Maddison, para 1910 sólo siete países en
todo el mundo eran más prósperos:
Bélgica, Suiza, Gran Bretaña y las cuatro
históricas colonias británicas por éxito
económico: Canadá, Australia, Estados Unidos
y Nueva Zelanda.
Incluso, brevemente entre 1895 y 1896 fue
considerado el país más rico del mundo.
De esta forma, en 1909, por ejemplo, el ingreso
per cápita en la Argentina era un 50 por
ciento más alto que el de Italia, un 180
por ciento superior al de Japón y casi cinco
veces mayor que el de su vecino Brasil
Pero, ¿queréis más datos?
Pues fijaos:
En ese mismo año de 1910 Argentina era la
primera exportadora del mundo de trigo, maíz,
carne vacuna, carne ovina y lana.
Entre los años 1900 y 1913, las exportaciones
argentinas representaron el 2,1% del total
de todas las exportaciones mundiales, y en
909 alcanzaron el 2,6%.
En el mismo período, Australia, tenía una
participación del 1,5%.
Menuda diferencia.
Simple y llanamente la Argentina volaba: el
campo hacía de este país una potencia agrícola,
las ciudades no paraban de crecer y al mismo
toempo los servicios y la industria tampoco
dejaban de crecer.
Pero un momento porque aún tenemos que destacar
un último gran cambio que se produjo en el
país.
Un cambio que hizo de Argentina todo un líder
en un campo que seguramente nunca hubierais
pensado.
Atentos.
(EL CEREBRO ARGENTINO)
En la segunda mitad del siglo XIX Argentina
hizo un enorme esfuerzo en educación.
Durante esos años se fundaron cientos de
escuelas e incluso se trajeron profesionales
educativos desde los mismísmos Estados Unidos.
Y eso no es todo.
En 1882 el presidente Julio Roca promulgó
la conocida como ley 1420 de educación primaria.
Una ley que instauró la enseñanza gratuita,
obligatoria y laica.Y, ojo, porque esto era
algo muy poco frecuente en la época.
Así que no puede sorprendernos que de repente
las escuelas y los institutos comenzaran a
brotar como setas por todo el país.
Gracias a ello en tan solo seis décadas,
entre 1869 y 1939 el analfabetismo se redujo
a menos de un tercio.
Del 70% a menos del 20%.
Y, vale, lo se, este dato puede seguir pareciendonos
muy alto.
Sin embargo tenemos que recordar de qué época
estamos hablando.
Por ejemplo, si en 1914 en Argentina el 35%
de la población no sabía leer ni escribir,
en España, por ejemplo, esa cifra alcanzaba
ni más ni menos que el 59%.
Luego, además, los estudios universitarios
también se popularizaron mucho más de lo
que era frecuente en el viejo continente.
En otras palabras, que Argentina crecia en
producción, en población, en infraestructuras
y, también, en formación.
Y lo hacía mucho más que los países europeos
y que la inmensa mayor parte de países del
mundo.
¿Recordaís la coña de la que hablábamos
al principio de este vídeo sobre la invasión
inglesa de Buenos Aires?
Pues lo cierto es que no hizo ninguna falta.
A principios del siglo XX, la Argentina ya
era como Australia…
Incluso, la capital argentina, Buenos Aires,
era conocida como la “París de Sudamérica”.
Sin embargo, desgraciadamente esa prosperidad
no duró mucho.
Y aquí creo que una imagen vale más que
mil palabras.
Fijaos.
No fue un mito, ese país existió, la Argentina
de éxito fue una realidad.
El proceso les llevó unos 100 años: Primero
se independizaron de España, en ese momento
este territorio era muy pobre.
Luego necesitaron 50 años hasta promulgar
su Constitución y ponerse en marcha.
Y luego otros 50 años hasta llegar al momento
de apogeo entre finales del siglo XIX y principios
del siglo XX.
Pero, ¿por qué se dio todo la vuelta?
Esa pregunta os la hemos respondido en un
montón de vídeos aquí en VisualPolitik.
Así que de momento…
turno para ti: ¿Creés que Argentina volverá
a brillar algun día?
¿Qué piensas que tiene que ocurrir para
que la prosperidad vuelva a este país?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios y
si este vídeo te ha resultado interesante
no olvides dare a like.
Muchas gracias por estar ahí, un saludo y
hasta la próxima.